hey everybody and welcome to an
honorable wild ride with stevo we've got
the uncrowned king of the ufc
lightweight division dustin the diamond
poirier who's just such a great dude
with so much integrity and a badass
fighter
now speaking of integrity let me tell
you about how i shave my face alright i
don't ever shave my face with any
products that are not made by harry's
okay they make the highest quality razor
blades which last
for the longest time
and they make them totally affordable
true story i've been using harry's on my
own
for like man coming up on two years
like way before they ever approached me
about a partnership man and i love him
because i used to buy these crazy
expensive
useless razors that like lit up and
vibrated and did all this dumb stuff and
i didn't need it man i have a closer
faster better shave
since i started using harry's and when
you go to harrys.com
stevo you can get a starter kit which
comes with the weighted ergonomic handle
the five blade razor a travel case for
the razor to keep it from messing with
anything in your bag and the foaming
shave gel and what is that a value of
thirteen dollars because they're so
affordable except with this deal you get
it for only three dollars plus you get a
100 money back guarantee if you don't
like any of it just send it on back and
there's no questions asked but dude
i love this company it's all i use i
actually need a shave right now so while
i shave
you go to harrys.com
stevo and get this 13 value starter kit
for just three bucks and start shaving
feeling good about it now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
dustin poirier yeah dude so dustin this
is my co-host scott randolph up in the
front of the van we've got the gorgeous
paul briskey we were talking hot sauce
before you came in good man yeah i've
got a busy morning this morning and dude
thank you for doing this well thanks for
having me on man
what would you say
if uh
i think that
you're the actual lightweight champion
of the world
i mean come on
i'm not brother i uh charles oliveira is
right but i do have
i do have 25 minutes to make it possible
make it make me uh the undisputed world
champion in december so right and that's
already set now for 267 is that right
yeah i just signed the contract and sent
it back off this week so everything's
finalized on my end
okay good and uh do we already have a
line on that because i'm guessing that
you're a huge favorite
i think uh
i saw somebody on the internet maybe
chill or somebody talking on espn saying
that the line came out and i was a
favorite but i don't know about how much
you know okay now that's interesting i
wouldn't uh i know you as a guy who goes
out of his way to avoid
like really
seeing a lot of stuff on the internet
and social media
i usually do like i
try to avoid stuff like that but i was
opened up youtube and you know they
recommended it to me and it said
something like chelsea
it was about my fight so i had it was
three minutes so i had to click on it
and check it out yeah okay you know
chill
i i i lis i listen to a lot we all we do
scott and i we we we like the trails
videos on youtube
yeah he's a
fun personality man
as a ufc fighter is there like a trusted
source for youtubers like chael or
anybody else that like reports on the
news of mma that that you would find
most credible or accurate
probably ariel right
yeah i i usually just talk to ariel and
uh
my management has you know can find out
anything we want so
i i i'll text ariel straight up
personally but that's that's who i
usually reach out to yeah i like ariel
man right thank you i hate to see all
this beefing going on with the
brendan shaw
i don't know what their deal is at all i
haven't looked into it but i know for
sure ariel's been straight with me you
know anytime i've asked him something or
he's told me something is you know it's
checked out for the most part
and like i'm kind of a very casual like
what's ariel's story like he he was just
sort of like kept trying to get his way
in and
has really planted himself as like a
staple in the ufc but was it not always
that way like how did he get where he is
not not just the ufc i think he was just
a mixed martial arts um media member
forever you know i'm a journalist
and uh
did a great job and kind of progressed
the ladder until he started getting his
own shows now and he's big enough to run
his own platform and his own thing so
good for him yeah yeah he's he's he's
killing it yeah so where are you at
right now are you in louisiana
yeah i'm in louisiana i fly out tomorrow
morning so i'm like packing uh
i'm trying to get all these loose ends
put away you know because i'm going to
be leaving for nine weeks yeah that's
concerned so you're going to start your
camp for the oliveira fight and that
means you're going to coconut creek
florida
yeah so tomorrow morning i fly out from
louisiana to coconut creek florida and
i'm probably going to spend
eight weeks there and i'll spend the
final week in las vegas right and and
coconut creek so this that's american
top team
yeah that's the amer so american top
team has a lot of satellite gyms all
over the us and globally now but uh
coconut creek is the headquarters that's
like the the big mecca yeah of where all
the yeah the main guys go this is dan
lambert's operation
yeah exactly and he's in there every day
you're running he's got a podcast now oh
cool man
so uh
you're like now american top team
notably has you i mean i got like a
million people but but really notably
maz vidal and colby covington were there
colby covington left
yeah massive all still there we got uh
amanda nunez
pedro munoz uh
joanna
yeah dude i don't wanna there's so many
people i'm gonna miss i'm gonna miss
people
i mean it's full of full of the biggest
stars in mixed martial arts right so um
so when you go to
coconut creek florida to start your camp
do you bring your family with you
i kind of um
now that my daughter's in kindergarten
so this is the first training camp where
she's in school you know she's always
been in preschool and mother's day out
type of things
all the the previous years so she's in
school now we have to get everything in
place to have a tutor come to our house
every day and keep her on the same
curriculum
but uh they come with me the whole time
now this this trip i'm gonna probably do
two and a half weeks by myself kind of
get tempered out there get used to the
workload get in my groove and then
they're gonna come meet me for the
remaining camp
right okay good man yeah do you have a
lot of weight to lose for the next fight
or are you pretty on point normally
throughout the year no i i always have a
bit to lose i'm probably
at 180 pounds or right under 178. wow
yeah yeah
plenty of time you know it's got to get
down to 155. all right yeah it's a title
fight so 155 on the dot um
my max weight even outside of training
camp drinking beer eating food i'm like
182 is like the heaviest i get so um
you know i don't get it sounds a lot to
you guys but like these other fighters
that i'm around on a daily basis that's
not that big of a deal
it doesn't sound like a lot to us
i wish i was overweight in like you know
182 185 we're slobs
no i'm talking about the uh
the difference to where
the weight loss right it's a pretty big
it seems like a lot to the average guy
but
guys have been manipulating their body
and making weight for years and years
know that it's very doable right i mean
it's all water right that's why the
sauna plays in so much yeah it's all
water for me too
really bad
it's uh
the final stretch is water but
throughout training camp these next nine
weeks i'm gonna slowly you know go down
and wait uh
over the weeks but the last push like i
would say the last ten pounds is water
out there in vegas
yeah
so yeah what is what does training look
like for you like is it like you know
rocky one where you're like the first
day you get out of bed like [ __ ] and
you jog and then it starts getting
slowly ramping up and
are you like hitting it pretty hard day
one two a day workouts and
yeah so i fly out there tomorrow friday
i have two sessions already scheduled uh
i got i have another one saturday sunday
i run five miles i mean i i jump right
right off the plane ready to go but
luckily for me i kind of train year
round here in louisiana i have my own
private gym and my buddies who i grew up
with fighting for like a lot you know
since the beginning now run their own
gyms out here and they have their own
stable of fighters and stuff so i'm
always in the gym when i'm at uh back
home in louisiana yeah i was gonna guess
that you're not like
a slob when you're not you know in
between fights you're you're still
keeping keeping in shape
yeah and it's not even so much that like
nine weeks is plenty of time to get in
shape it's it's more like the minnow and
the
technical shape like i got to stay with
the what's what's popular now what guys
are doing i got to continue to evolve so
i'm always in the gym working on stuff
you know working on my kickboxing my jiu
jitsu i'm always trying to learn um
i feel like these big gaps of leveling
up and fighting or between fights
because when i go to the gym i'm just
going to be prepping for this one guy
sharpening everything i have being
prepared to go on fight night the down
time right now i have is like i can work
on stuff that i wouldn't usually do and
have fun with it you know i'm not
cutting weight at the same time so i can
enjoy it a little bit more
and i'm always in the gym i'm a gym rat
yeah dude yeah um
now when uh
it was interesting i saw you after that
that uh
connor trilogy fight
okay since i'm about to talk some [ __ ]
with dustin poirier let me tell you how
excited i am about [ __ ] now that
i've got the hellotushy.com
tushy ace not only is it a bidet it's an
entire toilet seat with a remote control
that goes right on the wall which gives
you at the push of a button seat
temperature so you can sit down on a
nice warm toilet seat to take a big
sloppy dump and when you're done at the
push of a button you push bum and there
you go you have an adjustable
blaster to wash your butthole
like i mean dude it's the most
incredible bidet ever for the ladies you
can push a button and you've got the
front blaster
now when you get done cleaning up with
your varying
like power blaster all right then one
more push of a button and you're blow
drying your butthole people
this thing is insane
you've got to go to hellotushy.como
to be the first to get it because it
only just came out oh come on the tushy
ace i mean you're gonna feel like james
bond taking a dump with this thing it
was already my favorite
sponsor of this podcast i love tushy so
much and now with this thing they've
taken it to a whole new level and if you
get it at hellotischee.como
you get 10 percent off how about that
there is not a product i have ever
promoted that i am more thrilled about
than the tushy ace from
hellotushy.com plus you're saving the
environment when you use less toilet
paper and your butthole butthole's never
ever cleaner than when you blast it with
a tushy device from hellotushy.como
so get to blastin and now let's talk
smack about connor
and you know and there's the funny thing
where he called me a crackhead and uh i
i i obviously loved that what he did he
said that because you picked me right
right right i was down in um colombia at
the the stem cell spot that maz vidal
went to it's called bio accelerator
and uh you know i was actually hooked up
to an iv in this funny chair having like
stem cells flushed into my you know my
system
and uh
i saw like a text from dana's office
saying hey man can you make us a video
making your pick and i was like yeah
right on man and i said
uh you know my pick for
for the connor dustin fight is dustin i
said not only is uh dustin you know uh
just a better
nicer person
but it's not even gonna be close
dustin's gonna just march right through
him it's gonna you know
and so it was a little bit on the
insulting side i mean i'm not i'm not
surprised that that conor reacted
negatively to that but at the same time
man like he rubs me the wrong way a lot
you know and what really rubs me the
wrong way is how
like
it
i don't i don't like arrogance and and
promote i don't think fighters have to
be arrogant or or negative or you know
me like all the trash talk like
i mean
i i say that at the same time that i'm
like so invested in and disliking colby
that i'm like his biggest fan
you know but what i told you after that
conor fight is i wish that there could
be
like a new era where like the biggest
stars in mma are people like you who
have class and integrity and you know
like
honor
it it's just like and it's so great when
i said that to you you said man that's
what i want for the whole world forget
about fighting like what a great
what a great [ __ ] thing
yeah
you know like the cornerstone of martial
arts and stuff growing up was was that
to learn that through martial arts to
learn you know to be responsible to hold
yourself accountable
um honor and
they were built on that but at the same
time this is fist fighting so you're
going to get all kind of different walks
of life and and all kinds of stuff like
that and i try my best to i mean online
it's just so toxic everywhere you go so
i just any chance i can get to to try to
sprinkle a little positivity in there
that's what i try to do man so i try to
avoid that stuff but it's fighting so i
i don't want people to get like the
wrong image of me um
i mean well and i really want the best
for everyone and try to look for the for
the light in bad situations but at the
same time if i am if i'm if you catch me
out there talking trash it's because
it's real i would never fabricate a
disagreement or try to try to sell
pay-per-views with that stuff maybe it's
bad for business but it's just not who i
am and if i'm if i'm screaming [ __ ] you
to somebody's because i really mean it
you know what i mean yeah right and and
they can lick your whole [ __ ]
every every yeah
that was great that was a great destin
quote yeah my favorite said that was in
the octagon he said anybody who uh
anybody's booing can lick my whole
[ __ ] it's like
it's one of those moments that like the
whole world's watching and you said the
perfect thing and everybody loved you
after that you know what i mean i mean
dude i think everybody loves dustin no
matter what dude like uh
i i don't know man i'd like
it's it's tough when when you've got
somebody who's like such a big
such a big draw such a big star you know
like you got connor and he you know i
mean what he did for the sport you can't
deny it it's like he's definitely
it there's definitely a lot to be
grateful for for connor but
that's just how like the how it goes you
know
the the arena is gonna have their guy
and then if you're not that guy you're
you're gonna get booed
but at the same time man i don't think
anybody doesn't love you dude i think
that i think he got a a great just a
great reputation a great everything man
i'm [ __ ] stoked on you
i appreciate it man i'm thankful for the
journey for sure and i've been in the
ufc for for 10 years and
been fighting for a while i had the
documentary that came out when i was a
young fighter so i feel like a lot of
the fan base has got to see me go from a
kid to like a man and a father in the
sport so it's kind of a different you
know
um
story that they got to watch with me a
lot of these guys are
coming up or newer they make a splash on
the scene from me you got to kind of see
the whole thing
for the last decade right so i'm
thankful for that man sure
and i think that notably for you over
the the 10 years in the ufc
that
like if you look like it was like six
years ago the first conor fight like i
think that there's that there's a real
argument that uh you know that he got in
your head you know and that like and
that that's for sure
as much as your your fighting game is
involved i think that like really just
from a mental space like people can't
[ __ ] with you anymore and i think that
that's like
that that that's a big steve i i used to
care so much about like fighting was my
identity like that's who
i cared so much about it and it's crazy
like whenever you
don't really care as much anymore
you allow yourself to like grow and and
evolve and you know it's weird you think
the more you care
the the better you're going to be but
it's it's for me when i started letting
go and like caring less about all the
stuff that the more i felt comfortable
yeah and free and and the better my
career is going
dead and it's rad does that reflect in
your training like over the past 10
years has your training and your
approach to training changed drastically
yeah it it it has slowly over over the
years of um you know being around key
people in my my fighting life like
robbie lawler was a good buddy and we
were we were together a lot for a few
years and i kind of learned from him
like this is a guy who's i grew up watch
fighting and
he's getting ready to find his belt
again and and i'm like
watching the way he does it you know
he
one day he told me okay i think it was
this this is kind of what started with
him one day i was like nah man i can't
do that tomorrow i have to get up at 6am
and run three miles and he's looking at
me he's like dude fighting is your job
why do you have to wake up at 6am to run
three miles why don't you just wake up
when you normally wake up when your
body's ready to wake up and then run the
three miles i'm like god he's right why
am i scheduling myself and putting all
this pressure on myself to wake up when
the sun's coming up it's not going to
make me a better fighter you know i
understand if you have a full day and
you have to a lot of things on the
schedule and you got to squeeze time in
there to get a workout in but i didn't
that is my that was my day just to go
run and then go to the gym in the
afternoon right so small things like
that like why am i busting my own balls
to get this work done when it's going to
get done regardless well right
especially and depriving yourself of
sleep isn't doing any favor so i mean
yeah i mean just because i wake up
earlier than somebody and and go run
doesn't mean i'm going to be you know
more
equipped and ready and prepared to fight
i don't know man it's just been a
learning process this whole thing and
also
letting my body heal you know when i'm
running it to the ground in training
camp letting it recover like if i skip a
night session after a hard morning
session to let my just so i can feel
good i do better the next day um but
before when i was a young fighter i
thought the more practices i got in
that's how you get better so even though
i'm hurting and this is going to be
detrimental to me tomorrow i got to go
back to the gym tonight or i'm going to
lose this fight like i was so mental
about every single thing
yeah
so like with all the wars that you've
been in
like
i've been in some
i mean dude
serious wars
like
it's um
like like what's your how do you feel
about just like the brain
brain health is no joke dude especially
if you've hit your head like i have and
you know what studies have shown that
functional mushrooms like lion's mane
can actually regenerate your brain and
that's why my new coffee the only coffee
i'm drinking is called four sigmatic
it's made with fair trade organic
mushrooms and you know what it's also
delicious man
plus i got to deliver my new book on
friday so i'm staying on point and
working very late tonight so let's get a
whole new pot of four sigmatic dark
roast firing over here now they're
they're doing a special deal only for
the listeners of the wild ride podcast
which i'm very stoked about if you go to
4sigmatic.com
you can get up to 40
off of any mushroom coffee bundles plus
free shipping it's unbelievable man i
really think it's awesome because even
though it's coffee it doesn't give you
that like cracked out jittery feeling
there's no gnarly crash it's super
organic and you know what else it's easy
on the gut
if you're ever like getting gnarly like
gut problems from coffee dude not with
four sigmatic so come on jump onto
foursigmatic.como
get this killer exclusive deal support
the wild ride podcast and stay on point
man
like i am but hey get over to
4sigmatic.com for that killer deal and
let's talk about brain health like do
you feel like okay man like i just had a
gnarly war like with dan hooker that was
[ __ ] crazy like
i mean i met like there's countless wars
that you've been in do you think like
okay
my brain just got seriously traumatized
with like way more shots than any human
should ever take
now like
six months my brain will heal like like
i mean it's kind of a blurry line
between like [ __ ] up like
brain trauma and like what it can heal
from like where is that line
yeah i think the line is different with
everybody uh depending on genetics
depending on a lot of things you know
their lifestyle
but
for me i i after fights like that i do
the proper things to recover you know i
eat a lot of fats i take a lot of
supplements for the brain like brain
armor and uh you know just don't take
any shots to the head until you know for
months um i i try my best but at the
same time it's like i'm a fighter um how
safe can i be i'm doing everything i can
do but how's that can i be i understand
the risks when i sign these contracts
when i prepare for these fights i
understand what i'm doing
um if it you know it's fighting [ __ ] i'm
going to get my head cracked a lot you
know
in this journey and
hopefully i'll genetically i'm i'm right
one of those got one of those guys that
heal well from it and and like i said
did i try my best i still feel good
still feel sharp i think i have 46
fights uh i still feel pretty good but
we don't ride for free and that you know
right nobody rides for free man so
maybe it will in the future have an
effect but uh
i wouldn't change a thing man whether
i'm doing this fighting these guys
making a living for me my family or i'm
going clock in at an office sitting at a
desk all day i'm sure my spine will be
jacked up i'm sure i mean you don't ride
for free pick your poison i'm having a
blast yeah i i hate you i i agree with
you man people have always said man why
why would you do all these things crazy
things you do and i'm like man
in my view like a nine to five job
like is way scarier than any of the
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] i do
um and i'm not downplaying the risks of
going out there and fighting i
understand you know but but i accept it
it is what it is have you ever been
knocked out like real like bad like when
you're out cold or like you know i feel
like
what i've seen you know you take a lot
of shots but i don't know that i've
really seen you unconscious
i've been uh flashed
from conor in that first fight michael
johnson flashed me in 2015. when i say
flash i mean i go down and it's a tko
yeah but i'm not i'm not i'm not on an
airplane you know yeah yeah yeah when
dudes are snoring man that's [ __ ]
tough to watch
dude yeah like when when uh when maxwell
hit aspirin with that knee like that and
stiffen up and seize up that's tough to
watch yeah yeah that's really that
that's really tough um i i think that
when that happens i mean like it's a
sing in in in the fight game you hear
about people that have a glass jaw
you know like
yeah you i don't think you have a glass
jar
i don't think so either
yeah but uh
you know i i think durability over the
years is something is something that
does go away i think power's the last
thing to go away and uh durability does
go away as you age i i believe yeah
how old are you now
32 man yeah dude
good man and uh
you know like everybody talked about the
ufc you know like fighter pay and this
and that and like uh
but then
like a connor fight
makes so much money like
i it's hard to understand like the
like the the business of a connor fight
that's just the exception to the rule
like the ufc is just generous if you're
if you're fighting conor yeah it depends
your contract uh and and your
negotiating skills and all these things
coming to a
into play but yeah dude i passed up a
title fight to fight connor for the
third time
yeah
yeah so yeah i mean
dude and get those red pennies out baby
we made it
i don't think anybody um in the world
thinks that that was a bad call i mean
even dana was up there on the damn
podium at a press conference saying this
kid's doing the right thing you know it
kind of sucks because it devalues the
the championship but at the same time
dude i want to be the world champion but
i have i'm a provider man i have a
family and uh can't do this forever
right and as soon as that bum knee gets
healed up i'll whip him again
yeah dude
um
the uh
again it's just such a good decision for
you to do that and i think that like you
know the first thing i said is that i
think of you as as the world champion i
mean sure it's a formality you got to go
do this 25 minutes to get the belt which
like everybody feels just belongs to you
already it's kind of like you know like
and i don't want to like hype you up or
kiss your ass but i just think it's like
in in the views of the my point in
saying that is that in the in the the
consciousness of of the you know like
the fight world i think it's a
people see it as a foregone conclusion
that you're going to win that belt and
uh you know like
but is that scary
december 11th
when people are like i feel like you
already won do you kind of like oh i
gotta ignore that because like i didn't
win as long as yeah people can feel that
way as long as i don't wake up feeling
that way right
you know i still feel
i mean the guy is the is the champion
he's dangerous man he's he's very very
dangerous on the feet he's dead
especially on the ground well-rounded
fighter
yeah yeah very very dangerous opponent
um
so i have a lot of work to do you know
these next nine weeks is going to be
a lot of grinding and on fight night i
have to be perfect but i can do it you
know i can get my hand raised into the
world champion but during the training
like are you visualizing every night
before you go to bed like oh i did
already won or is there none of that and
you're just focusing on fighting
i i usually lay down and visualize like
ways i could win but i'm i'm
nothing's you know nothing's done uh
yeah day two of training
this fight could go maybe i clip them
with the shot maybe uh you know stuff a
takedown or get back i just
there's so much to mix martial arts and
so many ways things can go it's hard to
so every night it's like a different
scenario but i have great coaches man
and we break down a lot of footage and
uh we're going to put together a good
game plan that i'm going to execute
yeah you are dude
so how's the hot sauce going man
going good dude we uh going great we
just launched the ko edition uh yeah i
actually have him sitting right here
dude yeah let's promote that and and let
me tell you again dude
yeah dude that meant the world to me
when uh when you just done your own
on your own initiative your own time you
decided to go to my website and buy a
bottle of my hot sauce dude and then you
texted me a photo of it dude thank you
for that man thank you for that and
thank you for the bottle that you gave
me
in vegas you know yeah you gave me that
bottle
and uh and your hot sauce is delicious
man i i like to think that i could uh i
said that in in my youtube video that i
made
yeah we should send as much people as we
can to your amazon to buy the hot sauce
you got it on amazon
yeah we're on amazon now yeah yeah dude
that's the ticket man dude everybody
right now get on there and buy [ __ ]
dustin poirier's hot sauce yeah have you
been a big i bought yours because i'm a
fan of you obviously and i'm a fan of
cooking and a fan of hot sauce so when i
saw you had one i was like i got to do
this you know i got to see what this is
about it's it's great i love it but were
you a fan of sauce or you just jumped on
an opportunity what was that yeah i have
a condiment disorder
it's [ __ ] up man like i had like i
i i can't [ __ ] with food unless it's
just drenched in hot sausage
i'm like if we go to taco bell he orders
a separate bag of hot sauce and then
every bite gets a whole packet of hot
sauce in his mouth
he takes a bite and a whole packet of
hot sauce in his mouth there's something
about that uh taco bell hot sauce
packets that i kind of really dig man
but condiments in general and i love my
own hot sauce yeah and it's crazy too
because i came out
i came out with the the first one was
hot dog spirit butthole now i have the
butthole destroyer and you've got the
the regular or the original and the ko
that's great
yeah it's okay i'm going to check out
the destroyer man i need to get a bottle
of that oh dude
what's sandy we'll send you a bunch yeah
we'll send you some and then we're going
to be out of louisiana pretty soon oh
yeah how far away from new orleans are
you
about an hour 45 minutes are we in
florida oh yeah that'll be in florida
11th november 11th november 11th i'm
coming to new orleans
and uh and i'm super psyched man that
that's the first show on uh on a tour
bus run so we're doing like then you get
uh
didn't you get some [ __ ] in louisiana on
a tournament i did dude i did intend to
get arrested right um
it was it was in homeland louisiana
homeless that dude that's that's homer
just got devastated by uh
the hurricane man
but that's a hole in the wall there's
nothing out there in houma dude
right terrebonne parish
and and it was it was pretty messed up
man what like the big story the headline
was that i was um you know arrested for
stapling my ball sack to my leg you know
during one of my shows that i did there
on an old tour
um but the reason why that happened
like there was uh
you know i was i would always
chug a bottle of tequila during the show
and like and i just had it there
and you know since some someone climbed
on stage and stole the bottle of tequila
and these bouncers saw it happen and
they came over and like got it back they
were just super professional and then
and in the moment i said man these
bouncers are badass dude who wants to
try to run across the stage past them
we'll play british bulldog and they're
going to [ __ ] someone up so this this
one kid yeah me and and i set it up the
kid ran
and that these two bouncers they were
college football players it was
anti-climactic the kid ran into him and
they just grabbed him and then like on
their own deal man these two bouncers
lifted the kid up above their heads and
[ __ ] slammed him on the stage like on
his head and the kid was [ __ ]
twitching and like it was all it was
[ __ ] ugly man and i'm there i'm all
yeah covered in blood and [ __ ] like
yeah and i'm like yeah i mean like
they did they'd load the kid up into an
ambulance and and i come
[ __ ] back on the mic and i'm like
that kid's being loaded into an
ambulance is that what we came here to
do
it was just like
you know because in my head
i i you don't want to like
you know like i'm a circus clown guy you
know the show must go on and like in my
view like you don't want to acknowledge
that anything was wrong with that
because that would be like admitting
that it was wrong so i'm like let's play
another round of british bulldog like it
was bad man
and uh yeah you don't want to be
accessory to crime i mean dude like it's
exactly what you know and i was charged
with the principle to the second degree
battery it was a gnarly thing and there
was somebody in the audience filming it
and they were like man that was [ __ ]
up and they sent their videotape to the
news the news looked at the videotape
and said oh this isn't [ __ ] like news
this is a crime and they sent it to the
cops
and then by then the cops are like yep
this is a crime and uh and and on the
video i had my dick and my balls out and
i was stapling them and then when and
then you know when i stapled my balls at
night i said this is not art this is
strictly to be offensive
as i as i stapled my balls
like that that's the same show that was
in the same show dude and so like by the
time the d.a like whatever put the
warrant out i was back in l.a and and
there was a 1.12 million dollar bill
back in 2002.
you know like we we grow up dustin dude
you were probably didn't have to grow up
quite as much as i did
that might that that might not be true
you spent i never stapled my dick to my
leg but i've done a lot of dumb [ __ ]
yeah dude yeah
tell us about the juvie
uh when i was younger um around
you know freshman high school
uh coming out of middle school i was
getting in a lot of trouble and i didn't
do i did four months in juvenile
detention in louisiana that's not
it's a long stretch for a young kid but
that's what i mean that's not a hard
time or anything did you get any fights
in juvie yeah for sure man
a few of them did when i was younger i
was getting fights everywhere
everywhere because you loved fighting or
because you kind of had like this chip
on your shoulder or something or what
what was it i don't know i think when i
was a kid i think that's how i got
dressed every morning before i put my
shirt on i put the chip on my shoulder
every morning
just pissed off at it i don't know i
just i didn't i wasn't starting trouble
but i just like wouldn't back down from
it if i saw an opportunity somebody like
i would just kind of
you know i would start i wouldn't
like just go out of my way to start a
fight with somebody but if somebody was
was
talking crazy or something like that i
would turn it into a fight
yeah you're one of those guys that you
don't want if i've been in a couple
fights and like my my thinking is like
okay i'm gonna punch this guy as hard as
i can they're gonna knock out and like
the sad thing is when you punch somebody
and they want more you're like oh [ __ ]
dude this guy's just gonna kick the [ __ ]
out of me i feel like you'd be one of
those guys where you're just like the
more you can punch your face the more
you like it and that's a scary place to
be did that happen to me dude
that happened to me in uh [ __ ] was it
milwaukee i feel like i i and i'd been
awake doing cocaine all night i'm on
[ __ ] day
day two and now it's like okay i'm tired
i want to [ __ ] crash out and i'm
flying to milwaukee and these people
that picked me up they're like oh no
we're taking me out to the titty bar and
i'm like i don't want to go to the titty
bar and i got [ __ ] they they just had
me kidnapped basically they wouldn't
take me to the hotel so i'm like i go
out and but then i'm at the teddy bear i
don't want to be there i ended up i
don't know i don't want to i want to go
[ __ ] sleep i'm tired now like i'm
over it you know and i'm in the car with
this guy i've got my beer and this guy's
like oh no now we're going to take it
i'm like dude
like i'm [ __ ] piss i'm gonna i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ]
the guy's like what are you gonna do
dude you want the guy we're in a car
together too this guy goes
he goes do you want you want to fight i
go dude don't ask me if i want to fight
i'm holding a beer bottle
you guys like yeah
you just [ __ ] answer me and i
realized that holding a beer bottle what
am i gonna do with the [ __ ]
hit you while you're holding the beer
bottle the dude beat the [ __ ] out of me
really this is your driver yeah
i mean it was back in the day when like
it wasn't like big agents booking my
gigs
but the driver you hired kidnapped you
and beat you up
i mean i didn't hire the driver it was
like
[Laughter]
i think i might have like kind of tried
to hit him with the beer bottle but dude
that's just not me man did he take you
home after i remember i was i was like i
was marked up i was marked up i had been
punched in the face multiple times how
old were you dude
i don't know like 30.
dustin's age
yeah yeah wow that's prime that's prime
age to bounce back from an [ __ ]
yeah
so ah man our buddy theo vaughan
like how how long have you known theo
vaughn
well we're both from louisiana um
but i would think probably around 2018
or so uh when we first started chatting
online and then uh texting back and
forth and then i went to a show
and uh
yeah probably three years we've been
hanging out
he's been coming to my fights and stuff
dude he's such a good dude he's such a
good dude man he's such a good dude
he's good for him i know he's working on
his netflix special or he just finished
uh filming it so i'm excited to see that
yeah i think i think he taped it man and
now like
dude he posted a picture in this theater
that was like a huge
huge theater and he was like hey guys
thanks for three great shows and i'm
sitting there thinking he sold out that
theater three times god i'm jealous
yeah he came out he came out to
louisiana uh probably a year and a half
or so ago and did and put on a
comedy event for my charity and we saw a
lot of theater here in lafayette
louisiana yeah it was awesome right
yeah this is a good fight uh i mean dude
there's another great thing man that
like when the whole
like connor was going to donate but then
he didn't but then he donated to some
other louisiana charity your response to
that was so awesome to say like hey man
like it came in it helped the same place
you know like you haven't had no ego i
mean
yeah charity wins that's what it's not
my money it's not like it's going to
it's the people's money so as long as it
goes now hopefully wherever it goes that
those people do the right thing with it
but that's out of my hand you know but
it went to louisiana charity and that's
you know
sucks i had to twist his arm to get it
done dude you handled that pretty well
dude i i loved that
thanks man yeah and like hindsight you
know but looking back at it at all i
think he was i don't know if he was ever
really going to do it you know it's
steve the whole story is me and him are
going to fight in uh
abu dhabi for the rematch
mcgregor sports entertainment reached
out to to my foundation and said hey
we're gonna you know we need the routing
information we want the tax id or
whatever it was they wanted all the
information to start the transfer of
funds this is the week of the fight so
i'm like i go to the press conference
i'm like [ __ ] he's really doing and you
know hey i thank him in person in front
of the press connor thanks for doing
that it's going to help a lot of people
and uh they're in touch you know day to
day throughout fight week i go out there
sleep slap him and then they stop
responding to emails the money never
comes through you know we were reaching
out like right had the foundation maybe
send three or three or four emails over
the following next six months
they just completely stopped responding
you know it was a bad look and then when
when you put him on blast on twitter or
whatever it was and then he comes back
and says oh well you know we looked into
your charity and it's like okay you
stupid [ __ ] you know like you you you
made this promise to you pledged to
donate to it
like
and that and now he
i gotta give it to that guy though and
his damage control team they do
i get they got they get they get their
reps in you know they uh
the story they get
the story they came up with and you
never sent us the breakdown to where
funds would they never first of all they
never responded to emails after i
knocked his ass out
so we couldn't send a breakdown of
anything you know they never requested
one but it's just like the way these
guys that's what i hate so much about
like the being in the spotlight game
fighting and the social media stuff
because people can say things or like a
kobe comings people can say things and
the sheep listen and run to it and now
you're you're attacking me and my
foundation which is dude it's just crazy
steve oh man it's it's it's not because
like
we don't have i mean it's so much work
we do with this foundation we don't have
to you know the benefit i get from doing
this stuff is helping people out seeing
people smile it makes me feel good of
course but
that's the that's what i get out of it
like
it i take that stuff personal like with
the fight talk and i'm gonna knock you
out and and f you and stuff like that
i've been doing that for years whatever
you guys like to attack the foundation
something me and my wife have worked so
hard to build
dude it's like what the [ __ ] especially
when people from the outside start
hopping in you know yeah because like
you're
intelligent people
you know i don't answer to connor i
answer to the irs and myself every
morning when i look in the mirror i
would never put my
livelihood at risk
to you know what these guys accuse me of
doing trying to funnel money through a
foundation i don't even know how to do
that dude right i do i don't think
anybody i don't think anybody's taking
like any of those accusations seriously
all right i have a question right but
but a great
great way to like take the pressure off
of you whenever i said hey where's the
money you said you know the damage
control team is is good like i want to
say too that like i was surprised
you know
conor's got his leg broken [ __ ] joe
rogan's uh you know got the microphone
in his face and all those memes with joe
rogan holding the microphone
dude
everything that that started with the
the memes on the on instagram was so
good
but uh but while joe rogan's holding the
microphone to connor and connor starts
like popping off saying like his wife
was in mediums and it was just like
disrespectful as [ __ ] you know like and
i and i i spoke to you like immediately
after that fight and i was just like
dude i was like i can't like [ __ ] that
guy like he's like you know
he talked
talking [ __ ] about your wife and like
you were like totally unfazed by that
that like uh you said like dude i'm not
worried but my wife is rock solid like
that's like there's rocks and there's
nothing there like it was it was it was
shocking to me how unfazed you were by
him
like being disrespectful like that
and you know
and you were like what bothered me was
he said he was going to kill me
yeah
that was the thing for me the wife thing
i knew was i mean here we go again like
the the media and fans and stuff might
not believe whatever i say and and they
do believe what he says but like i've
been married 12 years killed my wife
since middle school like dude
it ain't happening you know i i know
that there's no question about it
but uh yeah the the stuff about killing
us and all that i felt like that first
of all you don't talk about people's
wives or children right it's a whole
nother he's a habitual line stepper and
it's a whole nother line you step
whenever you start talking about murder
and stuff you know right i think
everything going on with that guy is
like an actual like really pretty strong
argument that money does not make you
happy
because dude's not acting like a happy
guy
yeah
has he changed my i mean sorry to keep
asking about connor but has he like
changed
significantly
you know here's the thing dude and
khabib said it and and i heard it in a
couple other places and i think it's
really pretty true
is that money does not change people you
know like my money they'd be saying like
oh yeah we got all this money of course
it's gonna change
like the fact is money just
amplifies whatever you are you know like
whatever you already are you get you get
a ton of money now you're that but just
more you know because like for sure yeah
and so like here you know like i think
that you know you're you're doing pretty
well for yourself and like now you they
give you you've got a bunch of money and
the ability to be more of who you
already are and you're already a good
guy so nothing changes with you like
we can't make excuses
yeah we can you can't make excuses for
people being an [ __ ] because they
have money
yeah it's just it's just crazy like not
even a good guy steve just a guy just a
[ __ ] guy a husband a father just a
guy out here but it's so toxic in the
world you just be normal and try to be a
good you know just
do the right thing you get a label that
you're the good guy and you're trying to
do you know just from being normal being
[ __ ] doing what's right you know i
mean that's not that's not no i'm not
saying that
i appreciate your humility and i would
like to go back and correct you i don't
think anybody believes and then [ __ ]
like don't even like give credit to like
whatever conor disrespectful [ __ ] he
says about your wife like nobody
believes it you know there's no
credibility there and i i just love to
hear that the fan base is crazy people
believe it
all right all right i mean what what
whatever
um so now like
the
the craziest thing about fighting is
just that like here you know i mean 32
you're in your prime
but like you get to be 36
37 you know
like
i think about probably more than
anything
i mean athletics in general but probably
particularly fighting you want to be
kind of mapping out like what what's
what's the next chapter in my life like
what's and it's great that you what
you're doing with the you know with the
charity stuff but do you have like a
like an idea of
what you want to be working on like what
you're like
what later in life you want to be doing
yeah i'd like to continue uh
even
before i i made it like
in the top 10 of the ufc and doing
getting these big fights i always said i
would fight till i was 35
and then have a whole nother life after
fighting you know 35
going to do whatever you're going to do
i can go to you know go back to school
for a few years and still be young and
jump into another business so i've
always had the number 35 in my head
we'll see i still feel pretty good but
i'd like to grow my my
hot sauce business into uh where
pourier's louisiana style is actual the
company and we have a bunch of things
under under that you know like a
barbecue sauce seasonings dry rubs i'd
like to
turn it into a real culinary brand but
on top of that dude i have a lot of
stuff going on i have uh
you know trying to get more properties
get more into real estate
yeah
i'm trying to you know i'm just trying
to be smart just be smart because i
wasn't i'm learning on the job i wasn't
taught um
you know financial responsibility
um
everything i've got has been over my
career in fighting you know i don't come
from a whole lot of money uh my family
my you know so the people around me
so but i'm breaking that mold i'm gonna
do something with this man
that's great and you talk a lot about
how much you love cooking like is is a
restaurant part of the program
i would like to i have a buddy who owns
multiple very successful restaurants but
restaurant industry is one of the most
failed business ventures out there you
know and uh
i do know how to work hard and and show
up every day and make things happen but
well we'll see i had an idea for for a
traveling food show called food fight
and uh yeah
we're we're me and complex are shopping
it around right now so we'll see what
happens with that uh where i go to
different cities check out local
restaurants and local gyms you know um
i think that's a cool idea i came up
with so we're trying to make it work and
then like coaching the young kids is a
big thing right like you got like up and
coming fighters that are under your wing
you've been doing that forever right
yeah
yeah forever um but not so much like
very young i don't like to
i like to work with fighters who are
kind of already established and know how
to fight a little bit and this didn't
add to it and share my experiences and
my thoughts on combat with them
but i don't like to start on a fresh
canvas like if it's a young kid who
knows nothing i don't i don't really
enjoy that right now in my life i don't
maybe it'll change in the future but
like i i don't want to be coaching guys
and women from from nothing i i won't
give anybody their first tattoo man
yeah yeah dude like uh i want them i
want them to already be a mess
it's probably the same thing right you
don't want to like be the influence that
got somebody fighting's not for
everybody it's like here's your first
beer and they died of it like five years
later right yeah yeah maybe you can
teach steve how to throw a punch though
so he never has to get in any of those
situations again yeah or at least how to
hit someone with a beer bottle
like i said i don't like to start from a
blank canvas steve
i'm worse than that dude like i'm just
not like uh i i don't think i could i
could ever kick anybody's ass man
you'd be so good at jiu jitsu dude i
might let you know
there were a couple times where i was
faced with the reality of having to
fight and like my first instinct was
like just to duck you know like like
someone's gonna punch me like and duck
and then as soon as i ducked i'm like oh
look here's this person's feet and i'd
grab their feet and then and then like
kind of wrestle my way out of it where i
like hold the guy and then i'm like okay
we're not gonna fight all right
now i'll let you go
like that i can grab the feet that's
classic duck and grab the feet dude that
got me out of like
you're like bobby weave that guy got me
out of two fights
[Music]
yeah dude dustin's like god this is
horrible
right why not
theo's doing jiu jitsu now out of
nashville oh
[Music]
what's vanquish i feel like uh i've seen
other people wearing that
they uh it's a clothing line out of out
of the uk they've been sponsoring me
wow
um yeah you've probably seen them on
other fighters as well yeah
yeah
right on manchester so what's the rest
of you you said you're going to florida
tomorrow
yeah so my daughter gets off of school
here in about
a little bit less than an hour get her
back home
make her a smoothie like we always do
and then i'll finish packing my bag and
just kind of hang out with my family
until i take off because like i said uh
they won't be able to come with me off
right off the jump with this one i'm
gonna probably do close to two and a
half three weeks by myself right and uh
so just spend time with my family get
ready to put the work in man sweat
equity dude i'm i'm so stoked for it man
like uh i'd like i don't want to um
you know give you any like if it's if
it's bad for me it's one you know like
fighters like before they fight like i i
don't ever want to like hit him up or
like you know i want to just like leave
him alone and i almost feel like telling
you that it's a foregone conclusion that
you're going to win ah you didn't i
didn't say that like
i didn't say that i think that but i
didn't say that
yeah yeah but dude i'm definitely i mean
i hope i hope you're right but yeah it's
a theater the unknown out there man the
mma gods don't give a [ __ ] about your
history your journey it's uh
that that's what makes this sport so
incredible to watch you know you can be
the biggest favorite
right in history and go out there and
get finished or or lose a decision it
just it's fighting right do you prefer
fighting in front of an audience or do
you like or no audience like you did
during the pandemic i mean what's what's
the difference i've also during the
pandemic i only fought once i thought
that hooker and it was awesome man it
was like
more intimate
um
i've said this before like fighting is
already
hectic so walking out of a tunnel and
people spilling beer and yelling crazy
[ __ ] at you it only makes it like more
uh you know nerve-wracking walking to
the
the octagon so walking through the
through the uh apex it being quiet i can
hear my coaches that was nice man it was
different only you know the first time
i've ever done it
yeah that way
it was it was a great fight man i'm i'm
always rooting for you dude i hope that
like
when uh
you know
that
when you've fought in the past and and
then like i tweet like how i'm like
supporting you and rooting for you and
like what just what a class act you are
like uh i'm just squarely on your side
man i'm just so stoked to be a bro
i really really appreciate i really
really appreciate it man like uh you're
a guy that it's an honor to know man
thank you man i appreciate that
yeah dude what [ __ ] man like i can't can
we throw any
oh dude like i wonder if uh
you know
if is there anything that we can do with
the good fight like if uh if they want
to make the trip to new orleans when i'm
gonna be there
for uh i'm sure we could i'm sure we
could think of something yeah they wanna
if they wanna like come come by
and uh
you know that's gonna be the first that
we're getting on our tour bus that we're
gonna be on for like the two weeks after
that if they want to like come
someone wants to come even just grab
some [ __ ] to auction off or something
like
maybe maybe like incredible man for sure
yeah like i was like i could try to come
up with something uh something killer to
uh to auction off for you or we could
like put something yeah let's raise some
money for the good fight dude i'm down
with that and i won't even back out man
we'll respond to each other break your
legs
they're still recovering down there from
the hurricane and stuff so maybe we can
tie that into it and uh get some money
raised for something going on in new
orleans area yeah dude i mean i'd love
to come up with something to to to help
out and and um you got my number if you
want to loop in somebody from the the
good fight like just so that you're
gonna you're gonna be in florida just
worrying about your camp and if you want
to loot me in with somebody then then
we'll come up with a fun plan to uh i
mean maybe we'll even
maybe we'll even like sell some tickets
to the show it will promote
you know like but let's let's make some
let's make some noise and do some cool
shepherding for louisiana
that'd be great man let's do it all
right and i'll have somebody reach out
to you brother yeah please do and uh
anything else that we can draw some
attention to send people to
um
do you want people to buy it on amazon
do you want them to buy it on your
website
they can go to diamondfourier.com they
have a link there or they can go
straight to heatness.com or go to amazon
wherever you want
i love it man i love it dude and uh i
really appreciate you brother man like
let's let's link up as often as possible
i'd love to man i appreciate you
reaching out yeah thank you for the
support yeah december 11th yeah dude
it did mean that you're up on me i'm
coming after you
yeah dude i'm setting it up it's already
done you're gonna i'm setting it up
right now god damn i'm gonna tap his
little [ __ ] ass out
you're both pretty tall what are you
what are you waiting i do i'm six foot
and uh i said i sit around 170 107
young guys in the same way class you're
good to go i got my money on theo
later brother bye
yeah dude okay man um i love dustin
poury i really
enjoyed that man and uh i'm so rooting
for him all the time i also
love you for sticking around to the end
of the podcast
and uh
i absolutely have a [ __ ] in clean shave
and even cleaner butt hole and i am
super firing up this pot of coffee to
work on my book which i have to deliver
on friday and yeah i'm a little stressed
out but dude i'm
really gonna pull it off man i'm i'm
making it to the finish line and i
cannot think about anything except how
[ __ ] badass it is it's not coming out
until next year spring
like right after jackass forever's
supposed to come out
but i can tell you already
[ __ ] it's gnarly oh my god
alright dudes i love you thank you